on en parlait en début d'émission
l'académie de Versailles la plus grande
de France a été touchée par les émeutes
urbaines la semaine dernière pour en
parler avec nous lactrice Charlène
Charline Avenel alors dans la ville de
La Verrière deux écoles ont été
incendiées aujourd'hui les élèves de et
les enseignants de ces deux écoles
étaient au château et au campus de
Versailles c'est une initiative de
l'académie de Versailles pourquoi avoir
organisé cette journée pour les enfants
dans l'académie de Versailles la semaine
dernière il y a eu une trentaine
d'écoles et d'établissements qui ont été
touchés dégradés
dans les émeutes urbaines que nous avons
connues il y a trois écoles qui ont été
plus sévèrement touchés dont deux écoles
à la verrière qui ont purement et
simplement
disparus en fumée après un incendie
criminel et volontaire qui a touché ces
deux écoles alors je me suis rendue
jeudi dernier
juste après le cet incendie qui avait
lieu la nuit c'était une image de
désolation que celle de ces deux écoles
entièrement brûlées détruite dans un
quartier dans lequel l'école est tout à
la fois pour ses habitants pour ses
élèves et aussi pour ceux qui y
travaillent
donc on était en pleine sidération les
enseignants ne comprenant pas pourquoi
l'école avait été prise à partie de
cette manière pourquoi elle n'était plus
là ils étaient assez désespérés nous
sommes allés à leur rencontre avec le
maire le préfet et puis hier et
aujourd'hui il y a encore eu des visites
importantes notamment la présidente de
région qui s'est rendue sur place et je
veux dire que voilà on a été à l'écoute
d'abord de ce choc très fort pour chacun
à l'écoute pour donner de
l'accompagnement psychologique et puis
pour commencer entrevoir l'avenir alors
l'avenir la semaine dernière c'était
demain c'était savoir comment allait se
passer l'école vendredi donc on a trouvé
des solutions et puis on a commencé à
imaginer comment se passerait la semaine
qui suivrait et puis maintenant on est
en train d'imaginer comment va se passer
la rentrée donc tout est réglé
les enfants vont pouvoir aller à l'ERPD
la verrière qui appartient à la région
c'est une école de premier degré
régional tout à fait assez rare assez
atypique mais ça appartient en effet à
la région qui est d'accord et Valérie
Pécresse a donné son accord pour que
nous puissions à la rentrée scolarisé
les enfants et donc ces mises en place
une très jolie solidarité autour des
enseignants des élèves de tous ceux qui
travaillent solidarité qui a permis de
trouver des fournitures des fournitures
pour la rentrée on en manque encore un
petit peu de trouver ce lieu à l'ERPD la
verrière et donc voilà on est à l'oeuvre
pour préparer cette rentrée et pourquoi
le RPD c'était la solution la plus
facile à mettre en place c'est à
proximité donc c'était vraiment
assez à ses idéal je dois dire et une
configuration tout à fait agréable dans
lesquelles dans lesquels les enfants
vont pouvoir s'épanouir c'était
disponible en tout cas très peu rempli
et donc voilà c'est vraiment la bonne
solution mais il faut beaucoup de bonnes
volonté et beaucoup d'actions pour faire
les quelques mètres qui maintenant vont
nous séparer de la rentrée mais voilà je
crois que les enseignants sont très
soulagés de cette solution de la
solidarité qui s'est exprimée et de
pouvoir réaborder la rentrée sereinement
alors entre temps et bien je dis donc
lorsque nous y étions je l'ai dit
c'était vraiment la sidération le choc
et j'ai eu cette idée dans quel état
sont les élèves les parents et puis même
les enseignants le personnel de l'école
alors les enseignants étaient vraiment
très en questionnement y compris sur sur
leur rôle le rôle de l'école dans la
sidération de penser que des jeunes qui
peut-être ont été les grands frères ou
sont eux-mêmes passés par cette école
ont pu porter atteinte
à ce bien commun que l'école donc je
dois dire que jeudi lorsque je suis
allée les voir ils étaient évidemment
naturellement sidéré ils avaient les
traits tirés ils étaient éprouvés et
puis j'étais aussi très touchée par les
Atsems vous savez les assistantes
maternelles qui souvent travaillent et
habitent dans la ville et donc ces
personnes étaient choquées parce
qu'elles ont vécu des violences dans les
immeubles et donc voilà c'était le choc
et la sidération jeudi dernier
l'incompréhension également mais à cela
j'ai pu leur dire les parents les
enfants rentraient très choqué aussi ils
le sont encore et donc on les accompagne
sur le plan psychologique il y a eu des
cellules d'écoute et puis un dispositif
qui continuera à être ouvert pendant
l'été
personne ne comprend tout le monde est
choqué et évidemment il faut prendre
soin d'eux et ce que je leur ai dit
au-delà de l'écoute nécessaire au-delà
de leur dire que nous allions être à
leur côté et bien c'était que plus que
jamais l'école l'éducation était
nécessaire et qu'il fallait pas se
résigner bien au contraire que on avait
besoin de donc j'espère leur avoir donné
un peu de souffle
ce sont des écoles qui ont été visées
par les émeutiers c'est un symbole de la
République honnêtement je n'ai pas
d'explication
je n'ai pas d'explication à ce qui
suscite une incompréhension totale c'est
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs qu'on nous
sommes sidérés et cette école c'est une
école qui qui fonctionne très bien il y
a très beau projet pédagogiques les
jeunes de la ville sont passés par cette
école donc c'est incompréhensible
et il fallait pouvoir leur donner
de l'assurance sur ce qui allait se
passer nous l'avons fait collectivement
et puis nous avons souhaité leur donner
aussi un petit peu de joie pour finir
quel était l'objectif finir sur une une
touche positive en fait l'idée m'est
venue lorsque nous déambullions avec la
directrice d'école qui était très
marquée sur les cendres de l'école et
j'ai eu cette idée en lui disant mais on
a tous besoin de beau on a besoin de
respirer que diriez-vous devenir la
semaine prochaine à Versailles et j'ai
vu son visage éclairer alors que c'était
dans un moment assez assez difficile
pour tout le monde elle portait sur ses
épaules beaucoup de choses et puis le
soutien de cette équipe et donc quand
j'ai vu son sourire et et voilà la joie
et l'espoir que ça suscitait et bien
nous nous sommes mis en situation
d'organiser cette belle journée donc à
la fois au château dans le campus de
Versailles avec des ateliers
gastronomiques goût des ateliers aussi
d'origami je j'y suis passée tout à
l'heure et je ne sais pas si les enfants
ont eu le temps d'aller visiter la
galerie des carrosses qui avait ouverte
le château de Versailles je l'espère
mais en tout cas voilà j'ai vu d'abord
les traits des enseignants beaucoup plus
reposés que la semaine dernière
évidemment et puis j'ai vu des enfants
enjoués et qui je l'espère vont emporter
avec eux pour ses vacances cette
dernière image de leur année scolaire
qui sera je crois une jolie image
justement vous avez pu échanger un petit
peu avec les enfants qu'est-ce qu'ils
sont pensés de ces journées à ce que ça
les a libérés un petit peu des images
qu'ils ont dû voir aussi à la télé comme
n'importe qui alors j'ai pas parlé je
n'ai pas parlé avec les enfants de ce
qui s'était passé la semaine dernière
parce qu'ils avaient déjà eu pas mal de
d'assistante et notamment psychologique
dans là aujourd'hui on était dans la
joie dans la contemplation je les ai vus
notamment vous savez à la Grande Écurie
là où est le campus il y a il y a le
l'écurie de Bartabas donc il y avait des
chevaux pour certains c'était la
première fois qu'ils voyaient des
chevaux donc ils étaient ébahis contents
et trouvant assez beau ce qu'ils avaient
sous les yeux il semblait pas marquer
par ce qui s'est passé non je crois
qu'ils étaient heureux d'être ensemble
comme tous les enfants et de faire une
journée de fin d'année scolaire
dans la joie alors au tout début vous
nous expliquez qu'il y avait trois qu'il
y a trois écoles qui ont été sévèrement
touchés dans l'académie de Versailles
par les émeutes urbaines il y a l'école
du bois de l'étang à La Verrière l'école
maternelle dénoué également à la
verrière quelle est la troisième école
c'est une école dans le Val-d'Oise à
Bezons où s'est rendu la première
ministre et le ministre de l'éducation
nationale ainsi que le ministre Klein la
semaine dernière les dégâts sont moins
importants mais mes enfants
en tout cas la semaine dernière il nous
a paru vraiment important d'aller à la
rencontre des des enseignants et puis là
aussi de trouver des solutions et
d'accompagner les uns et les autres
alors dans l'actualité également
Charline Avenel les résultats du bac et
du brevet qui sont tombés ces derniers
jours cette semaine quels sont les taux
de réussite du bac dans l'académie de
Versailles alors sur le bac général on
est à
89,5% façon de réussite au niveau
académique
92,8% pour les Yvelines pour le bac
technologique
73,2% de réussite au niveau académique
et 80,2 dans les Yvelines et puis pour
le bac professionnel 72,7 au niveau
académique et 75,7 dans les Yvelines
donc vous voyez les Yvelines se
caractérisent pas un petit bonus moi je
voudrais féliciter tous les candidats
qui sont maintenant des bacheliers et
qui vont pouvoir rentrer dans
l'enseignement supérieur et pour le
brevet est-ce que vous avez les chiffres
également alors le brevet c'est le scoop
puisque les les données les résultats
sont sortis cet après-midi donc on avait
cette année beaucoup de candidats en
plus ils étaient 900 en plus et puis les
résultats nous donnent
90,35% pour la voie générale du brevet
pour les Yvelines là aussi un petit
bonus de
90,95% donc là aussi je félicite les les
jeunes gens qui ont passé avec succès ce
brevet c'est sérieux de passer des
examens et voilà ça suppose et ça
suscite la fierté en tout cas voilà les
jeunes peuvent être fiers de leurs
efforts et heureux d'avoir fait tout ce
parcours et alors l'année dernière il y
avait des collégiens qui étaient sans
affectation au lycée en raison d'un
nombre insuffisant de place est-ce que
cette année on va rencontrer le même
problème
à la rentrée on sera là aussi sûrement
un petit peu en tension sur les
affectations en seconde pour la voix
professionnelle
voilà ça s'explique à la fois par la
démographie qui est très dynamique dans
notre académie singulièrement dans
l'Essonne et dans le Val-d'Oise moins
dans les Yvelines et moins dans les
Hauts-de-Seine ça s'explique aussi par
le temps que prend la transformation de
l'offre de formation pour être
complètement compatible avec les à la
fois les souhaits des jeunes et puis les
besoins d'emploi et puis enfin et bien
tout cela traduit aussi les efforts que
nous avons encore à faire en matière
d'orientation pour trouver à chacun le
bon parcours bref une rentrée qui sera à
surveiller du point de vue
désaffectations nous sommes au travail
avec mes équipes les équipes de chaque
département pour et bien travailler au
mieux pour que la rentrée se fasse dans
les meilleures conditions et que les
élèves puissent
aller dans une voie qui leur conviennent
bien merci beaucoup Charline avenelle
d'avoir accepté notre invitation en
plateau je le rappelle vous êtes la
rectrice de l'académie de Versailles